oh we've had Vista as his name suggests
Jack bench knows his Birds
but his elderly retired farmers passion
is reserved for a bird that was once on
the edge of extinction last time I saw
her
oh they're happy today
these are young eastern bluebirds
they're the payoff for more than 30
years of planting trees cutting boards
and driving nails this is a box made out
of oil and this box has been out here in
Wilda well this makes it secure Finch
has built and posted nesting boxes all
over his farm and there are thousands
more these boxes all over North America
we all have different strokes this uh
but it is for the birds try to save the
birds we just think about it
we lost the Carolina parakeet because we
didn't care then nobody did anything
about it for most of the 20th century
the nation's Bluebird population
dwindled a shrinking habitat pesticides
and competition from other more
aggressive birds are likely culprits
behind the decline in numbers in my life
growing up I never saw blue bird until
he pointed out the first one in the
early 70s that lone blue bird triggered
childhood memories for Jack Finch back
to a time when the birds were part of
his everyday life
what really makes my day to get up early
in the morning just as the Sun comes up
be a bluebird up on top of the radio and
general singing the Bluebird was on an
endangered list at one time it was an
extinct list one time and now that's off
that is his back and mainly because I'm
making nesting boxes
the number of bluebirds has grown
steadily because of grassroots efforts
like those of Jack Finch let's go up
here and see if this lady's on on the
nest this Florence
she had fully existed he's still putting
in probably 16-hour active hours a day
and he's and all of that is in some way
is focused on the preservation of the
Bluebird